so hopefully everybody's got the
notebook in front of them and has
Seaborn either was installed or or we're
able to install it so obviously I'm
going to talk about visualization today
using Python but a lot of what I'm going
to focus on is just general data
exploration and what we call exploratory
data analysis and a little more about me
the data set is in that git repo it's an
old one as you can probably tell when
you look at the auto the prices of cars
being a few thousand dollars on average
or something like that but it's from
1985 but that doesn't that isn't that
important what we're really interested
in here is how do we take you know a
reasonably complex data set that has a
lot of different columns of different
types and visually understand it and
also tools that you can use to then
present observations you might have from
from visual analysis to your colleagues
and bosses and customers whatever so so
this whole idea of visualization
exploratory data analysis in the history
of analytics and statistics and what is
relatively new John Tukey who I was
privileged to know as a graduate student
at Princeton published this book in 1977
and this was sort of the culmination of
research he had done for about almost 20
years before that and he and before that
grap you know statisticians and other
types analysts there were no data
scientists obviously in 1977 that's a
fairly new term you know would put a
graph or two into something into a
report or into a paper but it was mostly
about tables and it was very theoretical
and Tookie stepped back and said wait
there's a lot you can learn
by visually examining your data really
trying to understand the relationships
in your data and you know using a
combination of maybe simple summary
statistics and in graphical methods and
that was a big revelation believe it or
not I mean nowadays I think it's it
seems so obvious but maybe it wasn't in
1977 another influence on me at least
but also on the whole field was this
work by built by Bill Cleveland who was
then director of the stats math group at
ATT Bell Labs someone else I had the
privilege to work with when I was at a
company called statistical sciences
where we commercialized Bell Labs s
which you know eventually became
open-source R and so bill very
systematically went about trying to find
different you know he basically tested a
lot of different ideas about graphics
and how you can subdivide and present
data and how people perceive it and he
tested it a lot of times on not just an
average person on the street you know
sample but on fellow scientists at Bell
Labs so it was amazing how many times
they didn't understand the plots that
other people were showing them even
though it was very sophisticated aliens
I don't do a lot with this here but I
just want you guys to be aware of
obviously Edward Tufte and Yale
professor still for a long time this was
his original sort of seminal book in the
early 90s also and again he he looked at
a different aspect of this than where
Cleveland and Tukey came from and he was
more interested in the clarity of the
presentation and so he has if you look
at that book you'll see there's some
interesting rules about you know what's
the ratio of actual information to the
amount of ink you're well in those days
ink cuz it was all on you know
mechanical plotters in those days with
screen pixels I think nowadays I guess
so
so our goals are just what I've outlined
here to explore complex data using
visualization look at different chart
types you can use because when you're
exploring complex data there's not just
one chart type you know you don't just
keep doing the same thing over try a lot
of different things expect to fail a lot
and keep trying different things and
then we hit this problem immediately
which is a lot of what Cleveland
especially was working on is no matter
how you represent computer-generated
graphics it's on a 2d surface regardless
of whether it's printed on paper or
nowadays we project it on to a computer
screen
it's basically flat right it's 2d and
you know maybe you could do something
fancy with VR headsets or something and
get a third dimension but complex data
has many more dimensions than that and
so a couple of ways around that we'll
use what we call plot aesthetics which
I'll I'll get on to and and also a
method which has been reinvented by many
people and I'll talk about that
conditioning or faceting where you you
basically do different group bys of the
data it's like a group by operation so
there's some resources here I put in the
notebook you know in two hours we're
just gonna like scratch the surface if
even so just on how to do stuff there's
a lot of useful information like
matplotlib which is as I'll show you is
it's kind of the base package for almost
all Python graphics there there are a
few exceptions like bouquet which we
don't have time to go into that do other
types of you know plotting base package
is but if you go to this website that I
gave you on its matplotlib org
/resources /h index there's just a lot
of stuff from tutorials and videos and
it's it's it's a books and and what and
this is pretty highly curated
this isn't just like some random list
this is pretty high quality material
some of you may have been with us in the
last session in this room for the pandas
tutorial and there's pandas Paideia org
slash pandas slash dice anyway you can
see it there there's this tutorial on
visualization which goes through a lot
of the basics of how to if you have your
data and a panda's data frame just a lot
of stuff you can do with very few lines
of code I'd say that's the main
advantage of this you can get sometimes
a long ways with not doing a lot of code
and then a relatively new package that
we're gonna take advantage of here is
Seaborn and which is the one I wanted to
make sure everybody had installed it is
his take the people who are doing sea
board and I think this is still a sort
of an in-flight project that there's
missing pieces and things that when I
work with it I feel like Tia really
there should be something here so I hope
their continued to do new releases of
this they seem to be active there seem
to be some active contributions going on
it takes a lot of more sophisticated
plotting ideas a lot of them from the
our world a lot of this stuff that that
was done earlier on and tended to be in
our and so are plotting was generally a
little bit ahead of Python world and so
they've tried with with this package pi
Seabourn
but also another package called ggplot
which tries to imitate the ggplot2
package the
revolutionised graphics in our but we're
not gonna you know I can only do so much
in two hours so we're gonna just focus
on Seabourn which is enough so we're
gonna do three different kinds of
plotting but but don't get discouraged
because the base plotting is always
matplotlib for all these you know and
it's for the ggplot package as well so
by the way if you have questions please
interrupt and raise your hand also I
think on the live feed we have somebody
monitoring the the Twitter if you're
online watching and you'd like to come
up with a question please do then we got
a microphone we can pass around for the
questions so so the first thing is we
got to just load this data and how many
of you are somewhat at least somewhat
comfortable with pandas I hope or have
been in the pandas tutorial just now
okay so it's a majority by far so so I'm
gonna load this data into pandas
dataframe I don't want to spend a lot of
time on pandas because we just had a
pandas tutorial that some of you may
have been in but so the basics are you
know Pete you know so I import pandas as
PD so PD dot read to CSV the file name
and I've assigned file name and then I'm
gonna give the cut there are certain
columns that are that have missing
values and so and they happen to be in
these columns these so that's a list of
my column names and so and and in this
dataset they don't use an NA or a miss
or a null or something like that they
use a text question mark as the missing
value it's just how it was coded so so
first I can I convert all those to a
numpy nan so basically a missing value
and then I drop
I drop them you know if they're and I
convert those also to numeric because
they show up because of the missing
values being coded as a text or a string
question mark they show up as string
columns whereas they're really numeric
so we'll run that whole thing and with
any luck it's gonna work and you guys
can run it on your local environments -
all right so whenever you're exploring
data you should get some idea of what
like what's in the data right don't
don't just start randomly doing stuff so
let's just look at the head of that data
frame with the head method so dot head
is the head method and I could say N
equals something here you know like N
equals 10 or something but oops but for
obvious reasons I'm not gonna do there
no idea what that happened so let me
just run that and you've got and so what
we see is just the first five rows we've
got some columns we're not going to use
I think the original idea this data set
originally was put together having to do
with insurance losses on different types
of automobiles but we're gonna focus on
their price because a little easier to
understand so so you have the make you
know who made it
what type of fuel does it use aspiration
aspiration means like how does the air
get into the engine like is it turbo or
standard number of doors body style
Drive wheels you'll see what how this
works as we go etc and then some things
about some features about the engine and
finally the price of the car
alright let me just fix that so okay and
we can if we just use the describe
method that'll give us again some
summary statistics on those columns and
let's just look at a couple of these
here like length okay so we can see
there's a hundred ninety five cars in
the that where we have a length value
the mean length I think these are in
inches is 174 the standard deviation
isn't actually that much considering and
and the range is actually from minimum
of a hundred and forty one to a maximum
of 208 so so it gives us an idea that
cars don't have you know they're not
super short they're not extremely long
they're in a fairly narrow range and you
can look at these quantiles you know the
25 percent the 50 percent which is the
same as the median which is pretty close
to the mean so that also tells us that
distribution of lengths of cars is
probably fairly symmetric right whereas
if we scroll over here to price
we'll see the mean price is $13,000
which like I said this is kind of an old
data set and and we've got the standard
deviation is quite wide actually 8,000
so we've got a big range of price in
fact prices go from five thousand
dollars to forty five thousand dollars
and and the median is ten thousand
dollars whereas the mean is thirteen
thousand dollars so so in terms of
exploring this data we know that price
is highly skewed so so those are just
some things there's other things you can
look at here but those are just some
things we'll keep in mind as we think
about what charts
what visualizations are useful to to
digging into this data set so so let's
so now I'd like to just go through some
basic
plot types and and introduce you to how
we make those plots which is you know
one of our objectives here so that you
come away with a working knowledge of
Python plotting and how you use it to
explore data and also how you can use it
to create presentation graphics so a
really basic plot that everybody works
with of course is a scatter plot and
well let's just do the first one in math
plot libe and the recipe I'm showing you
here is really simple so obviously we
have to import matplotlib dot pi plot
because we're doing it from Python right
and we're gonna use the plot method and
we can just say what values of x and y
we want and I want dot red dots okay to
worry for each data point okay so the
type has to be R for red and an oh small
oh for an O or a dot okay and notice
there's one thing since we're working in
a in Jupiter notebook and it's runs an
eye Python interpreter if you don't
include this magic command matplotlib in
line with the percent in front it will
not plot your graph in line I mean you
would normally think that would be what
should happen right you run a plot
command you'd want to see the plot in
the ipython you know whether you're
running in a night Python shell or an O
in a Jupiter notebook that runs ipython
but that's not the default you have to
say so so you can see what so just to
show you in code plot you know so I've
important matplotlib pipe lot as plot
PLT so I've got PLT dot plot and then
I've got X Y and type so it's pretty
simple right so go ahead and run that
and we got a plot
but and so we have price on the vertical
axis presumably and city miles per
gallon so some measure of fuel
efficiency of those cars on the
horizontal axis consumer can people see
there's a couple of obvious deficiencies
of just taking this kind of default
matplotlib plot can what-what are a
couple of them that you guys see anybody
yeah yeah and label the axis that's a
big annoyance yeah anything else you
guys see yeah huh yeah there's over
plotting that's a good one well we'll
get to working on that but there's
another one anybody else see it
yeah yeah the x-axis is chopping
actually the y axis is just scaled to
the max and min so the dots are chopped
down here on the bottom and and that's
just because we took the defaults we
didn't try to do anything fancy by the
way this business of not labeling axes
is is a huge when I you know I I think
was mentioned in my introduction I teach
data science classes for both UW and for
Harvard and it's a huge pet peeve of
mine because you get something like this
and you don't know whether you know it's
average shoe size versus cows born or
what you know what's this plot you have
no idea right it could be anything and
and so keep that in mind
so let's do a little better so I have
this in a panda's data frame as you saw
right that's how we loaded it and so I
can take that data frame I know that
prices and apply the pandas plot method
and I'll say the kind is a scatter plot
so kind equals scatter in quotes and
then I just say X what my x and y are
just like I did before and go ahead and
run that and you see it gets somewhat
new-and-improved plot right
it's got axes labels the these circles
aren't chopped off you still can't tell
how many points are over plotting here
very well we'll get to that but but at
least for one line of code we've got a
sort of more miles for her better better
output for just the one line of code
using the the pandas plot method that's
because pandas plot method is built as
an abstraction layer over the mat plot
line and you get more so I want you guys
to go ahead and try this yourself I'm
going to give you a couple minutes to do
this so do Auto price versus curb weight
and there's somewhere up here
if you look at the column names there's
one called curb weight which is C which
is as you can imagine sort of the weight
of the car when it's empty okay
so just give that a try
oh and to execute the code and if you
don't know in a Jupiter notebook cell
just hit shift in or with the with the
cursor anywhere in that cell and it'll
execute the code it's actually how many
of you have never used a Jupiter
notebook before only like two okay so
hopefully it's not too overwhelming
[Music]
oh there's a question way in the back
could you run the microphone back there
logging is oh yeah thank em so I can't
hear ya it's on hello yes so far y-axis
your y-axis starts with zero for me it's
starting at five thousand hmm that could
just be different versions of pandas
plotting
I'm not as you can see you can force X
limits and Y limits as attributes which
we'll look at a little bit about
attributes right now I'm not controlling
them so it's probably just a different
version okay was there another question
way in the back - nope all right
okay well hopefully you guys got
something that looks about like this it
may not be as we just discussed exactly
this but okay so let's get a little more
sophisticated here this is a really
simple recipe right every we're just
using one line of code we can specify an
X Y a kind and you know we'll get some
you can get some mileage out of that so
to speak but let's use some of the
matplotlib capabilities so so I'm going
to define a figure which I'm going to
call fig and it's plot dot figure and I
can you can if you look at the dock for
this there's all sorts of attributes
about grid lines and all sorts of stuff
right now I'm just gonna say fig size
equals six by six so it's gonna be sick
in at least the way I've got my notebook
set up it'll be six by six inches and
then now that I've defined that figure I
can say let's set up I'm just gonna do
one axis on it so GC a is a method
defines an access and so now I've got
you know Auto underbar prices got plot
so this is all the same as you just saw
before except now I say what's the axis
so I say ax equals ax here right so now
I'm now I've said okay don't just use
any default axis use the axis I'm
telling you to use and okay so now that
I've defined what axis it is I can set
all sorts of attributes including as we
just talked about excellent limits and
why limits and on plotting but I'm just
gonna say ax dot set title so I give it
a title set X label so I give it an
x-axis label I give it a y-axis label
and you see it doesn't look a whole lot
different than the plot I had before but
I do have my title here I do have sort
of more human readable axis labels so is
that clear how I did that to everybody
because that's kind of an important it's
simple but it's also important if you to
what we're gonna do
sure
oh so the question is why are we setting
all those attributes after the plot I
think the answer is it doesn't really
matter I suppose you could set them
before the plot it's just the key
because you're just setting up different
attributes of how the plots going to be
displayed and you're saying use this
access to the pandas method so I don't
know you could trick I don't know let's
try it let's see what if we turn it
around I think it won't matter yeah okay
you tried it and it doesn't matter no it
doesn't matter because it's just it's
just gonna run through all that and
you've only set one figure so anything
that applies to that axis it'll just
keep you know it's like a compound
operation it's gonna plot them and I
suppose the order they're listed in the
code but the end result isn't going to
look any different
okay so here's another eye
can you explain the difference between
figure and axis like can you switch the
order of those in the code the order of
I'm sorry the order of which big equals
plot figure and axe equals fig GCA
what's what is the difference well I had
to know I have to define a figure first
which is just a plot area the figure
that I'm defining when I set that figure
sighs it's just a plot area like you'll
see later we'll have multiple axes on a
figure so yes I have to create a figure
before I can say that it gets one or
more axes what if you create another
figure after that well then you're
starting another figure it'll everything
I'm plotting here if i define a new if i
run another figure method I'll be
working on a new figure
was there another question behind there
nope okay yeah hopefully you'll see that
because well we'll get to making
multiple axes on a plot I hope I hope
hope I have timed this okay so a little
exercise so take your plot that you did
before which as you recall was the the
plot of the price versus curb weight and
try to decorate it with a title and some
axes labels and what and also where you
can control the figure size you don't
have to do six by six and you can do
your own if you want to see four by four
or eight by eight whatever whatever you
know it doesn't even have to be
rectangular to tell you the truth I mean
you could do by
[Music]
did everybody kind of get that then and
you can also cheat and see what I did I
changed mine up a little bit I said oh
I'm gonna make mine wider as I made it
eight by six so if I've got a slightly
different aspect ratio than then the REC
that's where we have before for no good
reason at this point just doing it to do
it
okay everybody with us oh here's a
question the style oh you mean the
shapes and the colors those are
aesthetics we'll get to aesthetics so so
the question was how do you set the
types of points but we'll talk about
aesthetics once we've gone through the
basic block types so another plot type
is a line plot Oh
the unit at least the way I have my
notebook set up it's it's it's inches
but it's inches based on some scale it
never quite comes out in real inches on
my screen so it's it's a little it's
inches in somebody's scale but it's a
little hard to know usually if I'm
trying to do something like four more
press good presentation quality I'll
wind up just messing around a little bit
till I find you know a set of a figure
size that looks good
well I mean scale in the sense like here
I did eight by six so obviously this
axis is physically longer than the
vertical axis and you know pandas laid
out the numbers correctly you can do
things to control the I'm just taking
the default tick marks and labels but
you can do there's lots of stuff you can
do too if you want like more granular
tick marks you can also do things like
rotate the if you have a lot of tick
marks that need labels you can rotate
the text so it doesn't all jump jumped
you know if you keep getting into these
deeper things you can do a lot of stuff
of you can do just about anything you
want
given enough code and pain is the answer
so so I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
create a new data so so why do you use a
line so a scatter plot is good when you
have a lot of data where each you know
they're not ordered in any way right
there's no order to these cars in terms
of like price and weight or price and
miles per gallon or anything like that
they're just they're just whatever they
are right it's just whatever order I
actually I think they're ordered by
manufacturer alphabetically but that
that has nothing to do with the actual
data values right so but but Derek
cases particularly like time series
plots and some other cases where order
matters and so I'm gonna create just a
simple data frame here and all I'm doing
is using the data frame method on on a
simple dictionary that has an x and y
column and X is just a list of a hundred
numbers and y is the square though so
it's just it's just a gonna define a
parabola and so you so the only thing
that's different here now is notice I
don't even have to say what what the
kind is with my plot method here on this
data frame because line plots turn out
to be a default when you hit for two for
a for a two axis plot in in pandas Sam
and there you have it I mean it's not
it's not very beautiful but I just
wanted to show you guys the method for
doing line plots we're not going to do
much with that today but it is an
important plot type for certain types of
data so do be aware of it so bar plots
are a little tricky if you're used to
other plotting packages because there is
a bar plot method and you can see that
in this second set of code counts that
plot that bar but but it needs to be
based on counts not on you can't just
give up the column of from your original
data frame it there there is no that
method that bar plot method literally
just plots counts so what we got to do
is create counts and we're gonna do it
we're gonna look at the make make is
like the manufacturer and we're gonna
use the value counts method okay
everybody with me on that so we wind up
with this series a single one a single
column
pandas data structure is called a series
because it it's not a data frame it
doesn't have there's not multiple
columns so the index of this series is
just the manufacturer and notice that it
nicely orders them this is just a the
way pandas works it nicely orders them
from the most frequent car to or the
manufacturer with the most frequent cars
to the want manufacturer with the least
frequent and so now that we have counts
I'm going to apply the counts not plot
dot bar method - but - that counts
series not to my original data frame
okay it's a little tricky and notice I'm
using yet a different figure size here
but all the rest of this should be
familiar by now and well other than the
fact I picked - let me make my figure
size smaller so you guys can see it
actually okay so now we've got a nice
ordered and and something in terms of
perception your perception your
colleagues perception bosses and
customers or whoever you're going to
present to it's always very nice with a
bar plot to order it either
this is descending order or it could be
a sending order but if you order it
people don't have to look and go okay I
see Toyota is the most common but is it
Nissan or Honda in his Honda more common
than Mitsubishi you know you can hardly
tell right and they're only different
actually I think they're those three all
have exactly the same number of cars but
if they were just in some random order
people would really have to study your
plot to understand it you yourself would
so which is one of those things you want
to avoid when you're doing good data
visualizations so order order the lesson
is order order your counts either
ascending or descending and it may
matter you know depending on what you're
trying to do right so a histogram any
questions up to that point then or
okay okay so a histogram is like so a
bar plot notice this is discrete or
categorical data a car is either a
Toyota you know it has a manufacturer
and it's one of the in this particular
data set it turns out to be one of these
names from this list and but those are
discrete values a car can't be one point
to Toyota or something like that right
but I will also notice to somebody
else's question pandas plotting does do
this nice thing when you get too many
axes labels notice how it it knew to
change it kind of figured out that oh
I'm gonna get a lot of if I put those
labels horizontally which is the normal
way to do it there's going to be a lot
of over printing so it turned them
vertically so that you can see them
better but you can do that you can force
that too so so a histogram we have a
continuous variable like engine size
engine size and these data are in cubic
inches and there's there's no
categorical you know a car could have
144 cubic inch engine and could have 143
or 141 or you know whatever so or 144
point 6 that you know it is a numerical
you know it's a it's a continuous
variable it's not a categorical variable
so therefore we use histogram so
histograms you simply around some bins
create counts nicely pandas doesn't
unlike bar plots where they force you to
compute the counts yourself the
histogram does it all
automatically now one trick is if you
just did Auto prices dot plot dot hist a
it would try to make a histogram with
all the numeric variables plot it one on
top in in some funny way which
probably isn't what you want I mean
maybe sometimes it is so you need to
subset so I'm subsetting that data frame
to just the column I'm interested in
right now engine size and so so that's
why that little extra bit there with the
square bracket subset operator on column
is is being used and all the rest of
this is the same you know where we set
up a figure we define an axis we use
that axis for the titles and the in the
pardon the person once again you know I
should have gone through I'm sorry I
should have gone through and made these
all reasonable size you guys can see
them so here's a histogram of engine
size and so in terms of when you look at
this there's a feature of this histogram
that really stands out what what is that
anybody but the nature of these autos
anybody because you've got really tiny
engines down here and some really
ginormous engines up here but what do
you see about that distribution
it's very skewed right auto
manufacturers at least in the sample
tended to have cars with pretty with on
the small end of engine size there was a
question could you do this with like
curb weight and engine size like well if
you want to put two factor or two yeah
that's where you could you could you
could play around with having like a I
don't know if this'll I don't know if I
can do this in real time but I think you
do something like you have to insert a
list here let's see
I'm not sure hmm I think that'll work oh
you need one more bracket on the right
oh oh right yeah but you get to see this
is the problem you get this funky thing
right where I was wondering if you would
like group them together almost like a
no no it tries to plot them site in the
same set of axes if I was to you know so
this is so if you want to look at engine
size versus kerb weight for example
that's probably a better better option
to use a scatter plot this is a case
like what I was talking about right at
the beginning that you don't you know
you need to think about what are you
trying to view what of you know which
when you reach into your tool boxes of
plot types which plot type actually is
going to display what what you're hoping
for and you know you could do things you
could you could have two axes side by
side or one above another you know you
could show the two histograms if that
somehow meant something to you and your
analysis but if I was going to compare
those I would I would want to look at a
scatter plot that would be my first
thought all right so let's talk about
box plots how many people know what a
what I'm even talking about okay close
to half the room good so let me just
make some so so the idea of a box plot
the original ideas I think to keep
published this originally in like 1960
or something so it's been around a long
time
and the idea was if you have a bunch of
I think this may actually go to the
question we just had of like comparing
distributions of two different you know
four different variables so so what if
you have something like engine size that
we were just looking at and then you
have some categorical variable like fuel
type in this case I think these cars
either have gasoline or diesel engines
so there's only two fuel types and and
so so what we can do is we do we select
those two columns engine size and fuel
type and we use the boxplot method and
we say by equals fuel type so that's
like a group by so we're going to group
cars by fuel type and we're going to
display this box plot which I'll explain
in a minute and once again I got
ridiculously large I don't know what you
know it is probably that the projection
is lower resolution oops I didn't meant
to do it the other way sorry okay so so
what you can see is on the left hand
plot here we've got the diesel engines
the right-hand plot we got the gas
engines and then we have engine size so
so how do you compare these things so
the red lines are the median value so
you can see the median value the median
diesel engine is a bit bigger than the
median gasoline engine then one quartile
the date above the median and one
quartile of the data by quartile I mean
1/4 of the values below the below the
median that's what defines the box you
can see the boxes almost overlap here
then we go out another well either till
we run out of values or up to one and a
half quartiles and that's called the
whisker and then if we have outliers
beyond that we put these plus signs so
we can learn a little bit from a plot
like this it's it's not totally
definitive but it looks like maybe sort
of the bulk of diesel cars have maybe
slightly bigger engines you can see that
box is a little higher than this
it's probably not that significant given
the overlap but you can also see the
gasoline cars have a much wider range of
engines from you know barely fifty cubic
inches way up to some pretty ginormous
engine that's like 300 and I don't know
whatever that would be 25 cubic inches
or something much bigger than any diesel
car because you see those plus signs for
the outliers and so that's a way to
compare and you could have multiple
we'll look at some examples where we
have more categories and you can quickly
compare so so now we're gonna talk about
seaboard and Seaborn works a little bit
different from pandas plotting by the
way is everybody with me up to this this
point now okay good all right
so assuming he Seaborn successfully
installed which generally doesn't seem
to be a problem and I'm not quite sure
why all anaconda distributions don't
include it was there a question there
okay so the simplest recipe that I've
laid out here for making a seaborne plot
is to import the package which always
have to do set a style for the plot grid
and that's kind of like setting up the
axes for the other plots we've seen
although it's it's not quite the same
and you'll see why that is I think in a
while and then you you define and the
plot type and and you have to say which
columns you want that to apply to so in
this case so we implore import seaboard
as SNS and so then I have this method on
SNS called set style and I'm gonna pick
a style called white grid that's just
like the most generic style it's just a
white background with a with a grid it
you know gridded axes so pretty pretty
pretty simple pretty generic so then I'm
going to use a method called KD plot for
colonel
density against plot and I just gonna do
that on engine size just on one column
now again if you had several you know
you if you had columns for engine size
for you know diesel and gas or something
it could do different things here but
let's just do this real simple thing oh
and notice that sometimes you get this
weird deprecation warning so so this
looks a lot remember the histogram we
had of engine size so imagine that we
took a what's called a kernel estimator
which is like a Gaussian shaped curve
weighted curve and we ran that over
there and we found sort of a smooth fit
over that histogram instead of binning
we tried to get a smooth fit over the
density of curves and there's one other
thing they do
it's a density it's a probability
density so the integral over this whole
curve has to add up to 1 which is you
know one of the axioms of probability
right so but you can see the in this
case I don't think we're learning a
whole lot more we're seeing that as we
discovered before manufacturers have a
tendency to build cars with much with
smaller engines it's only a few sort of
outlier cars that have these really
large engines okay now notice also what
went away here because I didn't specify
I did this in a real simple way what's
what's missing yeah my axis labels and
my my title and all that because I
didn't do anything about it so let's
okay so you can probably guess that's
what we're gonna do next
so again we can define it define a set
of AXI to find a figure define a set of
axes and when we say that we're gonna do
this KD plot method we say ax equals x
and then we can just as we did with like
the pandas plots and you can do this
with matplotlib plots so that's why it's
important to kind of understand all this
stuff is coming up from map plot libe
this whole business of the set underbar
title set underbar xlabel etc is all
just mat plot libe stuff that can be
superimposed on another any other some
of these other plots and so now I've
kind of decorated this plot with proper
axis labels and a title okay so so
before we get off kernel density
estimation plots I just point out that
there's another thing you can do which i
think is actually sometimes really cool
and this is partly someone pointed out
that we had a lot of over plotting when
we looked at engine size versus price
and this is partly a way to get around
that oh yes what was the question
that's a deprecation warning I some
versions you get that it I actually ran
it down once and they said oh it's a bug
so after reading like pages and pages of
discussion so that's why I made a note
earlier on to just ignore that if you
get it I don't know it's anybody else
besides me getting it nope
oh few people okay so it depends what
version of anaconda you've got I guess
or which version the Seabourn you got
I'm not sure where it's I think it's
actually coming from matplotlib
not even from Seaborn but feel free to
ignore it and that's why it's a warning
it's not an error message it's a warning
and it also turns out to be an incorrect
warning because it's not actually a
problem
so okay so 2d plots 2d so it's the same
KDE plot but now I just give it a list
see I have square bracket than square
bracket you know
then a list with another square bracket
so I just have a list of so I've got two
columns engine size and price oh and I'm
also going to someone asked about colors
so the C map is like a like a color
palette I'm going to pick from and and
you'll see why that is and if you look
in the in the Seabourn documentation or
the tutorials somewhere down here
there's a whole new yeah color palettes
there's a whole yeah a lot of stuff
about color palettes they they do a
really nice job of color palettes with
Seabourn there's a lot of flexibilities
a lot of cool stuff you can do
they've also thought about like that a
lot of big percentage of people are
red-green color blind so they try to
steer away from red-green palettes and
stuff like that so it's whoever did this
really knew what they were doing
yes in the last tutorial when they were
doing the plotting it was a method of
the data frame itself what's the
difference between doing it in this way
versus the other way well okay so we're
not using pan this is now Seabourn so
it's a completely different thing but
you could also do some way back to the
pandas plotting let's see what was our
last like this one I think I could do
counts dot plot and then let's see well
we can try it it should be let's see I
think like kind equals and then I think
bar has to be in quotes and then I need
a comma all right oh and get rid of that
I think that'll come up with the same
plot yeah see
it the answer is it doesn't matter it's
a style thing I you can do it you can
explain Quentin did his pandas tutorial
he was using a style like this counts
dot plot and then he would say kind
equals whereas I am doing counts dot
plot dot plot method like this I don't
know do you like do you like arguments
to your methods or the list of methods
in your code I I they as far as I can
tell they're interchangeable I've never
noticed a difference so but it's a good
observation of the detail okay so let's
get back to yeah here we are
so so so I was explaining so I've got
this list of two columns here
that's so I'm subsetting my data from my
auto prices data frame to just those two
columns and I've set this color palette
so let's let that go
and there you go there's there's other
things yeah
I'm sorry you know I'm I tested this on
my standalone display which obviously
has more resolution than the projector
so all right so now you can see it so
you can see that there is in fact you
know this is like a contour map like a
topo map or something and you can see
what that color palette is doing it
starts out the lowest rungs are close to
black and the lightest rungs there's
such a dark blue they almost look black
and then the top rung is this really
light light blue up here right in and so
when we talked about over plotting and
that there were a lot of data points so
let's go back to the scatter plot and
you'll see what I mean
way back sorry so see in some of these
areas here there's just so many dots you
can't really tell how many are on top
one on top of each other and we call
that over plotting and this is only you
know we only have as we saw 195 cars in
this sample but imagine you were doing
this on customers for an e-commerce site
where you might have millions or
something this over plotting becomes an
overwhelming issue and so you need other
methods to deal with it so one of them
is this kernel density studi kernel
density estimation plot like this
another which I don't think we go into
is is called a hex bin plot hex bin
plots well I have a if you look at my
github you'll see actually I think I
just have a link to it but some work
Ryan - and I did where we were plotting
making scatter plots of every home sale
in the United States for the last 20
years or something like that was a
fairly big data set not giant you know
not big data big but big and we use
these hex bin plots and it gave a
similar effect whereas if we had done
scatter plots we just would have had
blobbs it would have been so many dots
one on top of the other it just would
have been an you know an interpretable
blob so when you're making plots if you
if you wind up with blobs think about
other methods like this 2d kernel
density estimation or hex bin plots so
is it clear to everybody why this is
giving us what it's giving us and what
do you conclude from looking at
something like this oops I was a
question
you mean this plot oh yeah right because
we're doing engine size here it gives a
legend but in this case I've given a -
I've given a - columns that we're sort
of contouring over so it's price on the
vertical engine size on the horizontal
you don't really need a legend Oh a 3d
plot yeah you can do that in math plot
libe I don't think there's any 3d
plotting and Seabourn in fact I'm pretty
sure there isn't so so the answer is you
can do it with enough work with
matplotlib primitives in fact I think in
those the resources I gave you if you
click through that and look at some of
those tutorials there's actually some
examples of that but it's a lot of code
so be warned if you really need to do it
do it I'll also make the comment one of
the key non 3d plots because they
they're so dependent this is something
Cleveland looked at and some other
people I think I think I think to Steven
talks about this that it depends on if
you have a 3d surface imagine you have
to have an eye point of perspective and
how people will view how picky and rough
your surfaces depends on you know how
its oriented and so it can be very
tricky in fact you know pipe you'll
notice I don't I mean there's a number
of types of plots I don't use I don't
use 3d plots generally I don't use pike
pie charts because I think I think it
was Tookie said they're an excellent
tool for off you skating almost any any
point you're trying to make even though
if you look at like infographics and
news sites and stuff they're very
popular but but if you think about it I
have some examples for another class I
teach which is longer and we look at
some having to do with elections in
various countries where
there's a lot of political parties I
mean it looks like some sort of
psychedelic pattern you cannot tell who
which party has what percentage of the
vote in the parliament or something like
that
because it's just it's just useless so
so anyway what but but what do you guys
when you look at this plot it's it's
it's actually telling us something
pretty interesting I mean assuming
you're that interested in the price of
cars but what what is it anybody yeah
well I wouldn't say they're the same so
I don't think that's quite true because
the units are quite different for one
thing but they do they do tend to be a
lip I mean there is a high covariance
right they get down to be elliptical you
know so anything with ellipses sort of
indicates you know where the elongated
ellipse on these contours but there was
just something even more obvious than
that
yeah so hundred well cutting its cubic
inches but yeah there are lots of cheap
cars with hundred cubic inch roughly
engines on the market in 1985 so because
it's there's a clear peak and there's
only one peak in this loser others it I
think there's a question way in the bank
okay
yeah
yeah so you'll get yeah if it's so the
question is if we did this with city MPG
you get two you get you actually get a
little more complicated so first off
there's obviously some outlier cars that
that oh well this is city miles per
gallon I didn't change the label
apologies anyway so there's some pretty
low fuel efficiency expensive cars there
seems to be a cluster of those those I
actually I can help spill the beans
those are luxury cars so they're not
built for fuel efficiency up in that
corner and then you see yeah there's two
modes of this where manufacturers either
want these really cheap high fuel
efficiency cars or kind of mid I imagine
they're sort of midsize cars or
something like that so yeah so you can
you know this is a good point though
that you know you want to look at lots I
mentioned this when we started you
always want to look at lots of views of
your data and this is a you know there's
only 20 20 columns or something that
we're working with in this data set but
you can see even with just 20 columns
there's a fair amount of complexity here
that if you were trying to really
understand this and maybe you were
trying to build a machine learning model
to predict the price of cars based on
certain attributes or something like
that maybe for your competitors if you
work for a car company or something you
know you you would really have to work
quite a bit to fully understand this and
be able to create an a deep
understanding of what what these data
are telling you so another interesting
plot plot is the violin plot so it's
very similar to the box so it kind of
combines the best of box plot and
density plots and so kind of like the
box plot we have an X which is a
categorical variable and it should
always be a categorical variable
fuel-type and then we have a Y which is
a continuous variable so we'll just use
engine size but we can use price we
could do you know you could use lots of
different columns and like I say in
practice if we were really doing this
exploration as a real project we'd be
doing probably hundreds or thousands of
plots till we figured it out but let's
just do this one okay and so you can see
it looks like you can imagine that
kernel density estimation plot we looked
at for engine size before where you just
looked at all cars so you could imagine
so it's it's got the same thing on the
left and on the right it's just
symmetric so you can look at either side
and it just shows you there is a
distinct peak in the gasoline cars and
kind of the diesel cars their engine
size is sort of more uniformly
distributed right and you can actually
see they've done a little box plot II
kind of thing in here the dot the white
dot is is the median and you can see the
upper the upper inter the upper inner
quartile the lower inner quartile you
know etc and you can also see as we saw
before with the box plots there's a lot
of outliers in gasoline cars there's
apparently a lot of gasoline cars with
really big engines ok so everything
we've done up till now everybody ok up
till now ok so so let's so we're gonna
now switch gears we're about halfway
through our time or a little more and
we're gonna start looking at ways to
extend beyond two dimensions everything
we've done has been one or two dimension
one dimensional plots like histograms
and the 1d kernel density estimation 2d
plots like the scatter plots and the
contour plots and things like that so
let's start looking at aesthetics and so
the first is so we're gonna look at
color transparency size marker shape and
some plot specific aesthetic
and so color color is a very tricky
aesthetic it seems very simple like oh I
can just color but but there's a lot of
problems I already mentioned the issue
that a lot of people are red-green
especially men for some reason our
red-green color blind so when you think
of what palette you're going to use four
colors consider those kinds of things
Seabourn actually does a pretty good job
of suggest the palettes that are kind of
the standard palettes try to avoid ones
that are hard for colorblind people but
there's a method in Seabourn called and
and also don't pick too many colors I've
seen plots I just saw one the other day
where as we were working on and and
someone had done like 20 colors and you
couldn't tell the difference between all
these shades of red and all these shades
of green and we were going back and
forth and back and forth between the
legend and the and the dots and the you
know it was very it was dependent on
every everybody saw something different
you know so so don't go crazy with any
actually that's true of any of these
aesthetics you can show a certain number
of other dimensions but you can't show
huge numbers of values so this LM plot
it just means linear model plot but I'm
actually going to set rigged fit to
false because I don't want to you get
regression lines is what happens on the
plot which can be really useful but in
this case I don't want to confound what
we're really looking at which is we're
gonna set the hue as fuel-type and I'm
going to use this set to palette okay
so right away so you can see what
happened here
fuel type sir gas or diesel and you can
see the the red dots or the diesel and
the kind of greenish dots so I guess
they did pick red green in this case but
or at least I did the blue I guess
they're more like blue green but anyway
so so you can see something now
interesting about this price versus
miles per gallon which which is what
what does that tell you about gasoline
versus diesel cars anybody
yeah you get more mileage for your for
the amount of money you spend on your
car if you buy a diesel car which is I
mean everybody probably knows that but
this demin you know you can see that in
almost every case the diesel cars are to
the right of the gasoline cars at almost
every price level and remember before we
saw this clump of kind of very high cost
low efficiency cars those were these
luxury cars if you don't believe me you
can you could make a plot you just do
like you know Mercedes and Porsche and
Jaguar and a few makes in a select and
you'll see that's true so or you so it
gets a little complicated I don't want
to spend the we just don't have the time
to go through this but I wanted you guys
to see you can get a lot more control
and you can use the pandas plotting
methods in this case I'm gonna create
but I just want to give you the general
recipe so what I did is again I define a
figure let me make it smaller see guys
so it doesn't spill out again I set some
axes and I basically subset my data
frame for gas so I've met create a two
data frames here for gas and diesel and
if I had four categories I'd have to do
four data frames and then I apply and I
also make sure that there's something in
that data frame so the shape the first
shape shape is the the number of rows
and the number of columns in the data
frame so shape zero is the number of
rows so if the number of rows is greater
than zero I'll go ahead and plot it
because I don't want to error out if I
have to in this function if I happen to
have it but that's a this kind of a
technical detail so I'm gonna plot both
of these and you can also do this as a
list I mean it's there's probably more
elegant ways to do this but I thought
this was more straight and so I've got
kind equals scatter I guess to someone's
question that was before way so in this
case I'm not doing
the plot method as a dot I'm doing it as
a kind and I'm gonna give those colors
dark blue and those red and everything
else is oh and then I'm I'm doing some
I'm creating some legends here so I just
do that and I have essentially the same
plot you just saw using Seaborn a lot
more code but I just wanted to show you
guys for future if you you can get a lot
more control this way at the expense of
a lot more code so let's look at
transparency so we looked at over
plotting and one method which was the 2d
scatter plots
but so now now we get to something where
you have to do what the recipe I just
showed you because I can set something
called alpha and by the way alpha is the
same in Seabourn it's the same in
matplotlib it's the same in pandas so
alpha is a transparency value so alpha
of zero is completely transparent you
wouldn't see the points at all alpha of
one is what we've been working with it's
perfectly opaque you can't see through
it at all so we're gonna try 0.3 and you
see these single points up here look
pretty pretty fuzzy now and you can
start to get some better idea of down
here where there's over plotting where
there's really a lot of points or maybe
just one or two on top of each other
okay so transparency is pretty useful so
so here's a little code exercise for you
yeah we have time for that so copy just
go ahead and do copy-paste and do this
kind of do the same thing for engine
size and curb weight so this is like
price and and city miles per gallon but
go ahead and create a similar plot for
engine size and curb weight you can you
can try the pandas or you can I'm gonna
I think I'm gonna try it with Seaborn
see if I can get it to work because that
would be
Oh for those of you new to notebooks if
you need a new just go insert cell below
and you get a cell for your code what
did I say engines
yep
that's the problem doesn't have to do it
okay so you see that's why
okay so Seaborn doesn't know about alpha
there's a way to do it
all right
huh cue it didn't like it
you mean the alpha oh let's try
so that's the argument
No yeah okay I'm remembering this now
yeah but it's I'm trying to remember is
it is it an argument - LM plot or
something else you apply where do you
have to do another call on SNS with a
different method
yeah I think it seems like something you
ought to be able to do but
[Laughter]
yeah
okay so maybe
I just can't
[Music]
all right
so I kind of did it the hard way
although it sounds like there's a better
way to do it with with Seaborn but you
get the basic idea that it's just a
different view of the data engine size
and curb weight not too surprisingly
pretty highly correlated and generally
diesel engines
if you turn actually you can flip the
axis around you'd see that cars tend to
have somewhat smaller engine size per
weight if they're diesels okay so the
last thing we've got here is marker size
and marker size is is is again one of
these tricky things that you don't want
to get too carried away but you can use
it on a continuous variable and so this
is the same code we've been working with
and I'm just going to and what I've done
is S is for the size attribute you see
and it's and I did point five just to
get a scaling of Auto prices of engine
size so now we're gonna so well let me
make this plot and then you'll see
what's what's interesting about it so
you see the size of the dots now varies
with the engine size you see we've got
gas and diesel cars we've got price and
cities miles to gallon so how many
dimensions so I advertised that we were
going to look at multiple dimensions
using using these aesthetics so how many
dimensions are we actually plotting here
now from our multi-dimensional data set
I think somebody's saying four yeah
that's right so we've got type of engine
fuel we've got engine size we've got
price we got cities miles to the gallon
but can you guys see that there's kind
of a a little bit of a problem it's a
little hard to say I mean these dots
aren't that different in size like from
these these luxury cars with the really
big engines and clearly you can see for
some of these economy cars they're
smaller but it's not that distinct right
so one trick is to to go with engine
size school squared so I've got Auto
price and so I've just multiplied the
two columns together here you could
create a new column in the data frame
too and you can see that don't you think
that makes well let me let me rescale
that for you
so I think I mean that to me to my eye
and probably to yours doesn't that look
a lot different that you can see these
cars with these really big engines over
here and a few down here and really
small engines in some of these other
areas so so keep that in mind so the
difference is this is now engine size is
now proportional to the area of the of
the shape and you can change shapes to
we'll talk about that in a sec and as
opposed to the linear dimension of the
shape so this is work people like
Cleveland and others have done that the
human eye is more sensitive to the area
of the shape you're looking at than the
linear dimension and so finally we are
going to use marker shape so so I know
it's getting kind of confused so we've
got size we've got color
we've got alpha and then we're going to
do marker equals m'kay so I've got this
list of zeros and pluses and a list of
colors
and you can see turbo cars are dots are
and standard or and stand I'm sorry
yeah and standard cars or crosses so if
it's a turbo it's a circle if it's a
standard car so yeah once again say I
did not think to I didn't think about
how how different the resolution would
be on the screen so there you go so how
many dimensions are we now projecting on
to this two-dimensional surface
anybody just lost five yeah five is
right because we've got whether it's
standard or turbo we've got whether it's
gas or diesel we've got the engine size
we've got the price and we've got the
fuel efficiency so five dimensions on a
two-dimensional so we're using three
different plot aesthetics here which at
least the way I did it here is a little
bit quite a bit of code but that's not
so important I'm going to skip a little
bit of this yeah it could be I should
have used triangles or something yeah
this question is the plus shapes maybe
don't look as weighty is the equivalent
dots yeah maybe to some people's eyes so
you could use triangles or squares or
something like that there's there's ways
to do yeah that that might have been a
better choice perhaps something that you
see an area so let me just go here and
do so plot specific aesthetics are lots
of things like here I'm just gonna do
this real quick with histograms so all
I've done is change the number of bins
so we're back to pandas plotting here so
in one case I just took the default in
one case I said bins equals for you so I
think the default is 10 and you can see
they're pretty chunky bins right but it
looks but the but the histogram looks
kind of smooth and easy to interpret
what's the problem with 40 I mean you
see more detail but but does that really
tell you more what do you think the
problem is there
it's just looking at noise it's just you
know it's just it doesn't mean that much
that it's just jumping from one little
bin to the next by so much so obviously
I've picked too many bins so when you're
creating things like histograms density
the density plot you can set up what's
called the kernel width
think about and try different things to
find something that suits your data now
if we had you know ten thousand values
instead of one hundred ninety-five maybe
even smaller bin wits would start to
make sense for a histogram but we only
have a hundred and ninety-five data
points so we can't push the push it too
much so a cool thing you can do we
already looked at color with Seabourn
with some of those other plots but here
I'm doing hue is aspiration I'm doing
this for that violin plot so it's the
same violin plot we looked at before
with fuel type so you've got you know so
again we just set set our grid you know
we we apply the violin plot method fuel
type price aspiration so the new thing
is this aspiration and when split equals
true so you'll see what that does in a
minute
so what it means is now we get remember
before we had just the two sides of the
violin plot we're just mirror images of
each other they weren't different at all
but now we can see whether they're
standard or turbo on either side and it
shows it in a nice different color so
this gives us a way so we've out got how
many dimensions on this plot three yeah
three so we've got whether it's gas or
diesel
we've got whether its standard or turbo
and we've got the price and you can do
the same thing for engine size etc or
with box plots let's do something a
little different so body style there's a
lot more body styles
yeah
sorry I can't
so in the violin clutch up there in this
plot yeah so there's a median and and oh
the median is skinned for the whole
group it's not it's it's not giving you
like two medians and two you have to
look at the density plots on the left
and the right to get the differences yes
so you could create other subsets or
other variables too so so I we don't
need to go through this but you can see
if you buy because there's five body
styles you can see get quite different
box plots for gas and diesel depending
on whether it's like I think one of
these is a convertible etc so I just
wanted to show you that okay so yeah
okay so we've got half an hour so I
think we've got enough time to do a
little exercise here so and so so we
just looked at that violin plot so try
it with Drive wheels so just make the
violin plot a price so it's price by
aspiration but make the hew drive wheels
and you'll see it'll be different
there's three types of drive wheels I
just wanted to show you just see so it's
pretty quick to do that just do some cut
and paste
I think that's right know what's the
variable name yeah I gotta go all the
way back out
hmm I have wheels
that parasitic yes but if you report
oh I'm sorry yeah it's not the heat oh
right I should have kept the hue the
same it's the it's this should be Drive
wheels and the X so you can do it
that's what you get and this one then
should be fuel type
okay right okay yeah that's what I
wanted to show
so yeah and the point is like as the
error message is the person pointed out
the error message said yeah you can only
have two to a two-level categorical
variable to do this color split so
obviously I could use gas and diesel or
ik or fuel type or I could use
aspiration but there's interesting thing
with four-wheel drive vehicles what do
you see
yeah there's no there's no diesel
four-wheel drive vehicles in these data
so but you know and you can see that
every one of these four front wheel
drive vehicles you can see that they
tend to be the cheap cars regardless of
whether they're gas or diesel they're
all clumped down there at the cheap end
rear-wheel drive cars have this big
range and in four-wheel drive cars for
some reason or down there so ok so I
promise we're gonna look at multiple
axes types and so let's spend the rest
of our time on that so this so
everything we've done has just had one x
axis one y axis up till now so now we're
gonna look at multi axis plots and
there's a couple ways to to skin that
can't and this is a scatter plot matrix
it's called a joint plot in Seabourn and
we're gonna do engine size by price and
so a joint plot is just a scatter plot
as you see and then it gives you the
histogram of what what we would call the
marginal densities along that edge so
that's why it's called a a.split plot
but you see we we've added these extra x
axes which are the the counts or the
densities on the edges so that's just a
simple example of now a plot that the
you know tells us something new but is
quite you know but you can't create a
plot like that with just one pair of
axes right so another more complicated
plot is a pairwise scatter plot and
Seabourn has this thing called pair plot
these things I probably seen him before
they've been around for a long time at
least 30 years and we're going to do I'm
going to define the numeric columns to
be these this you can do categorical
columns but I'm just gonna stick with
numeric columns we're gonna use fuel
type as hue and we're going to use that
same palette and on the diagonal I'm
gonna put kernel density plots and I've
set a and we're gonna do KDE plots those
2d kernel density estimation plots on
the upper diagonal so you'll see this
this might take a little while to
compute here
hello a warning message which choosing
to ignore for now okay so there's a lot
going on here as you can see so here
we've got so the way you read this is
you've got lengths curb weight engine
size horsepower city miles per gallon
price then you've got exactly the same
variable names on this axis so so you've
got price by length down in this corner
here you've got price by curb weight but
if you want to look at curb weight by
price you let's see
curve would see so you can see the
kernel density plot of let's see curb
weight by price will be this one here so
you can see there's sort of two peaks in
that you can see for gas and diesel cars
because that's what we used as a as the
hue you can see the histogram or the
kernel density plots for each of those
so so now so now how many how many
dimensions do we have on our plot
count them up nine because we got eight
eight numeric columns plus fuel type as
a categorical so we got nine all right
so someone asked this question about
multiple plot axes and so the way we
kind of snuck into this once before but
so I can so here I've got my figure and
my axis that's typical Python stuff
right with the comma because I have to
this function is going to return or this
method is going to return two things a
figure and an axis they do plot dot
subplots two by two so that means I'm
doing a two by two array of subplots and
this is like way too big a figure your
size you'll never see it I'm going to do
eight by eight and then so I'm just
gonna say so so I've got an X so this
little function so I can say what my X
column my Y column are and we're just
going to do histograms so you can see a
subset with some kind of gnarly notation
here and then plot dot hist so I'm
actually using Matt plot lives plot
method histogram method here so I've
gone all the way down to the base math
plot libe for no good I mean I could
have used paint I could have created
data frames here and and use pandas or
something like that or Seabourn but it
was just easier well at least in my view
it was easier to just create two lists
called X calls and white calls and
iterate over over them or enumerate over
them
but the important thing is then you see
I do in fact have it well I've got all
sorts of over plotting here so I'd have
to work on this more right to get these
separated a little bit and all this but
I think you get the idea that the key
thing that I've done here is I've
defined a figure in a set of axes that's
a two by two array of axes you guys all
see that that's like the important thing
to notice here and and you can see I'm
having problems I've got some over plot
printing and and I can't really read my
axis and my axis labels are a little
funny and I'd have to go back if I
wanted to compare these histograms I'd
have to go back and create code to make
sure that the the the x axis lengths
were exactly the same on each of these
but fortunately there's an easier way to
do this which is called facet plotting
and so that this if you run into this it
can be called conditioned plotting which
i think is what Cleveland originally
called it it can be called the method of
small multiples which is what 250
originally called it it can be called
facet nowadays most people call it facet
plotting it's sometimes called grouped
plotting so it's it's but think about it
as a group by operation where you divide
your data and then plot it on multiple
axes okay and the basic idea is remember
we just created a standard grid before
with Seabourn but now we're gonna use
this facet grid method and I'm gonna say
columns equals drive wheels so I'm gonna
do a group by drive wheels and so
whatever I plot here and I use this map
method I'm gonna use a rake plot of
engine size and price and I'm not going
to show that regression line so is that
clear with what's going on there that
we're creating a grid which only has
columns so it's a one row by
however many columns of drive wheels
which will be three and then and then
I'm plotting engine size and price okay
so so there you have it and you notice
some interesting things first off the
axes facet grid methods make the axes
exactly all the same length so I can
compare one plot to the other to the
other so that's really nice it also
figures out that I don't really need
another set of axes labels here and here
I can just use those and so so it just
saves me a lot of time and it does the
group by Matt you know the group by I
don't have to I had that gnarly stuff in
the code here where I was effectively
doing I could you know a grouping or a
sub setting so and you can do like let's
try one with drive wheels by body style
so we got now we're doing columns and
rows okay so our grid now is going to
have two dimensions this is a one
dimensional grid this next set of code
it's the same engine size by price but
we're gonna do it we're gonna create
subplots by drive wheels and body style
alright and you can see there's three
types of drive wheels and there's
actually five types of body styles so
it's a lot of different plots there's a
couple things you can see like like
there's no four-wheel drive hardtops you
see there's there's no dots there right
there's only one there's only one and
you see how I'm reading these it's body
style equals hardtop drive wheels equals
front wheel drive there's only one so
most hard tops whatever I'm not even
sure what a hardtop is but whatever they
are they're mostly rear-wheel drive cars
and you see start to see
you know some price relationships for
these different subsets so this is a
very limited data set as I keep saying
it's only 195 points but if you had
thousands of points and you wanted to
explore high dimensional projections of
them this gives you a really powerful
way to do it this this facet gridding
method and you can anaesthetics so like
let's do hue of fuel-type so this is
basically I'm just making the same plot
you just saw with fuel-type and you
don't see so again you don't see many I
think the diesel cars are the red dots
so you don't see any like there are no
convertibles with diesel engines so you
don't see any red dots in fact there's
no four-wheel drive convertibles so so
there's no dots there at all and then
but here you start to see sedans with
front-wheel drive and they're kind of
tightly clustered compared to say sedans
with rear-wheel drive which have a wide
range of prices and an engine sizes so
so it's not the best example of using
this kind of scatter plot but so one
last exercise if you guys want to hang
on for a bit we actually have time at
least by the schedule so go ahead and do
this but change one of the axes to city
miles per gallon instead of engine size
because remember we started with that so
you can pretty much cut and paste and do
a few changes here
but we'll keep all the other the
faceting variables and the color the hue
as fuel type etc so it's really a pretty
minimal change
and Hindus nurse
[Music]
so everybody get it and it's just a very
simple change here we just had to change
change this to city miles per gallon and
you can see yes I do you see some
interesting stuff like again sedans with
rear wheel drives have a big range of
price and a big range of fuel efficiency
but there are no highly fuel-efficient
sedans right there
they just sort of end there kind of in
the mid range front-wheel drive sedans
have better mileage and you keep going
down here
let's see where the hatchbacks oh yeah
hatchbacks so you can see the all the
really really fuel-efficient cars or
hatchbacks so even though we don't have
an ideal data set to use this kind of
gritting method here you guys can see
that what the value is in terms of
dividing data into small pieces small
chunks and being able to compare it on
exactly the same axes side by side by
side there's also ways if you want it to
free one axis and not the other you can
set that there's all kinds of
specialized things you can do with this
and you have to think about as you're
visualizing a data set what to do so in
summary I hope I've given you a bunch of
tools bag of tools and and also pointed
out some places you can go for the
tutorials and what to learn more things
and giving you know so you know how to
do this with Python and also looked at
kind of the process of how you explore
data and why you explore data and stuff
you can learn from exploring data when
you have complex relationships and you
really want to understand it before you
you know waste a lot of time doing some
complicated analysis where you don't
really understand what you know what the
simple relationships might be between
your variables
so that's so are there any questions or
anybody Oh got a couple back there yep
so the question is can you make these
graphs interactive not with the packages
we've been looking at you can do some
animation like matplotlib has an
animation system that's actually kind of
cool so you could like step through a
bunch of categorical variables or
something so it I just didn't have time
to go into that if you want truly
interactive Python graphics I suggest
you look at the bouquet package which is
a whole we could do another two hours
just on that it's it's its own world but
it but it's and it's it's the other nice
thing about is it's it's it's directly
usable in websites so so it actually has
a couple of really cool things about it
but it like I said it's a whole other
thing
oh yeah there's lots of stuff on bouquet
I think there might even be a bouquet
Booker to it yeah yeah oh yeah right
someone's there's a talk on Friday yes
for sure but not a tutorial in this
conference
although would be nice there was a way
in the Bay
yeah yeah that's a good suggestion to
the I pi widgets if you want to do
simple simple interactive stuff those
work pretty cool those are pretty nice
too for in there specifically for
Jupiter so if you're doing it in Jupiter
then then you that might be what you
need there was a question there yeah hi
so I'm relatively new to this
visualization with Python and let's say
I have an idea for a plot I want to make
how do I decide where to look for how to
learn how to do that matplotlib Seabourn
pandas how do I decide yeah it's not
know so the question is given all these
different packages and we just breezed
through like the surface of three of
them how do you decide I you know I
don't think I don't think there's like a
best answer to your question my general
rule of thumb is this I look at see born
first usually because it's it it is more
abstract you know they abstract a lot
more things as you saw we didn't write
nearly as much code to get fairly
complex plots out of it second might be
pandas plotting if fish if your data and
pandas dataframe and then I kind of you
only use matplotlib if I have to really
get into some detail and I hope that's
some helpful guide line but it's not you
know that there isn't like a absolute
best answer it really depends on what
you're trying to do unfortunately any
other questions or oh it's just funk
thanks Stephen thank you
[Applause]